ce n'est pas tous les jours qu'on
assiste à l'implantation d'une toute
nouvelle culture
et pourtant c'est le cas au bas saint
laurent là bas certains producteurs
misent sur une petite noix pour
diversifier leur production ou même se
lancer en agriculture on avait déjà de
la noisette en région dont on imagine
que nous soyons bons pour ça
si éventuellement on est capable de
faire une production commerciale
allons-y 60 motive beaucoup
toujours avec la la motivation va être
de faible à du bas-saint-laurent un
pilier de la production oiseaux
la noisette pas la petite noisette
sauvage
mais la grosse celle qu'on cultive s'il
n'en tenait qu'à maxime tardif elle
deviendrait pour le bas saint laurent ce
que le bleuet est au lac saint jean
un fleuron un produit phare pour toute
la région
ce qu'on envisage nous de vraiment
extraordinaire c'est d'avoir une chaîne
de valeur complète ici au bas saint
laurent
oui des producteurs mais oui aussi une
unité de transformation
oui décidé d'aider des gens spécialisés
par exemple à travers nos groupes
conseil qui seront en mesure
d'accompagner ses produits par là dans
l'art dans leur implantation
il ne s'agit pas d'une idée en l'air
mais d'un projet soigneusement planifiée
qui implique plus de vingt agriculteurs
de la pocatière jusqu'à matin sans
surprise sainte à mettre en place ce
réseau là maxime tardif travail pour
biopterre un organisme voué au
développement agroalimentaire et agro
forestiers c'est le responsable du
projet noise
tout a commencé par une vaste
consultation
on voulait vraiment aller chercher un
projet phare et c'est à travers un
comité qu'on a formé entre les
différentes mrc qu'on a décidé suite à
des rencontres avec monsieur madame tout
le monde et des élus et des développeurs
que la noisette pour être notre projet
phare dans le cadre de
d'un développement régional
une des raisons de ce choix c'est que la
récolte des noisettes sauvage fait déjà
partie de la culture locale
on est en terre inconnue je suis
hollande je ne ferme puis des noisettes
on a vraiment ça tous les ans pour le
plaisir d'un rang c'est un as été mon
premier commerce biopterre a décidé de
faire des parcelles d'essai pour voir
quelles variétés de noisettes allait le
mieux pousser et dans quelles conditions
on a lancé un appel d'offres
la réponse a dépassé les espérances 11
et si on ne sait 7,8 producteurs on va
être très content c 130 personnes qui
ont levé la main sur les 130 on en a
retenu 22 distribués selon les mrc le
plus à l'est d'entre elles jean-marc dur
est producteur de pommes de terre et de
fraises près de matane c'est une
diversification pour mon entreprise
un peu comme ça que je les ai vus parce
que c'est un autre production
je t'ai appelé à me diversifier parce
que chez lui comme chez les autres on a
planté en 2018
une centaine de jeunes noisetier issus
d'une vingtaine de variétés différents
julien où elle est lui est à
saint-roch-des-aulnaies à l'extrémité
ouest de la région
c'est un débutant en agriculture il
travaille dans une banque
quand biopterre a lancé son appel de
projets il venait d'acheter un terrain
en friche et comptait y implanter un
verger diop par la fonte est arrivé dans
les mains environ d'un monde un monde à
mon échéancier est arrivé dans les mêmes
eaux que le moment où j'en étais
qu'est-ce que je mais de quelle façon je
implanté sur un centimètre de plus le
projet le jour de notre visite on y
planter de nouveaux arbres parce que la
première année du projet on en avait
manqué à prédire
on en reste de l'amérique du nord le ou
au plan du noise et hybrides nordiques
comme ici il ya des problèmes
d'approvisionnement pourquoi parce que
la la la la demande a vraiment monté en
flèche depuis quelques années alors que
seulement un certain nombre de
pépiniéristes le bas saint laurent est
en effet loin d'être la seule région où
on plante du noisetier l'intérêt pour la
noisette et à la hausse un peu partout
au québec mais on ne sait pas trop
comment la cultivées de façon
commerciale
tout est encore à faire il n'y a pas de
rupture de disponible pour le québec et
même en ontario sont vraiment en avance
par rapport à nous pour la noisette mais
il utilise les réseaux culture qui
proviennent d'autres cultures fruitières
r comme la vigne comme la framboise le
bas saint laurent s'est donc lancé dans
une aventure un peu risqué pour mieux
évaluer ses chances de succès nous
sommes allés à saint fulgence
au bord du magnifique saguenay
rencontrer l'homme qui a probablement le
plus d'expérience dans le domaine au
québec
bertrand grave elle cultive des
noisetiers depuis plus de 20 ans c'est
un pépiniériste
j'ai acheté bien loin assis en 1992 un
groupe et beta l'ontario même
saskatchewan manitoba du
nouveau-brunswick pure et plantes à 113
oublier quatre cinq ans plus tard j'ai
commencé à avoir quelques noisettes
c'était comme un grand de deux petits
mirror que nos hôtes est extraordinaire
les noisettes était beaucoup plus grosse
non loin de travail et piqué pont
c'était quelque chose d'extraordinaire
vous voyez nous sommes aujourd'hui il
exploite avec ses enfants un verger de
2000 arbres en pleine production et ils
offrent de l'auto cueillette depuis
quatre ans bertrand gravel est optimiste
pour l'avenir de la noisette du bas
saint laurent
je pense que sincèrement que ça va être
une région adéquat pour la culture des
noisetiers
d'abord le climat y est plus doux qu'ici
à saint fulgence même si le verger est
sur une bonne terre est protégé des
vents du nord le froid menacent toujours
cette année par exemple les fleurs on
manquait de chaleur et de temps sec
la pollinisation a été incomplète les
arbres n'ont que 35% des fruits qu'ils
auraient dû avoir plus au sud
ce genre de situation risque beaucoup
moins de survenir
[Musique]
quant à la demande bertrand gravel est
très confiant
les producteurs du bas saint laurent ne
devrait pas manquer de clients chez lui
du moins les gens se bousculent pour
venir cueillir des noisettes on sur la
page facebook ou sur 2000 abonnés ça
c'est ça tout les réseaux taz quito tout
ça nos amis ex château richer euros
d'après moi sur son opinion au dessus de
2000 personnes qui voudraient venir
cueillir des oiseaux bertrand gravel
mais toutefois les producteurs en garde
contre deux ennemis le premier est une
maladie la brûlure bactérienne en
ontario elles causent de graves
problèmes nous ici ça fait 15 ans qu'on
apport à la porte plainte et un autre
arbre parce que on n'a pas de cette
maladie là pendant environ puis la
maladie
un peu pour s'installer trop trop dans
notre secteur parce que on n'est pas
dans les vins justement du des grands
lacs et du fleuve saint laurent puis on
a un beau vin du nord-ouest qui a pas de
malade il en a aussi compté
l'autre ennemi est un insecte le baladin
de la noisette
c'est un charançon qui pond dans le
coeur des fruits sa larve finit par
manger entièrement l'amande et prendre
sa place
cet ennemi là est déjà presque partout
les cueilleurs de noisettes sauvage le
connaissent bien
dans certaines régions pratiquement
toutes les noisettes sont parasités dans
le verger des graves elles seulement 3%
des noisettes sont affectés mais c'est
déjà trop parce que ça fait des moins
jeunes qui sont suspicieux ont ce
prochain vers mais même s'ils n'ont 1%
aux prochains horaires ou pas puis marin
vert année le roman rien c'est pas bon
bertrand grave elle travaille depuis 15
ans à résoudre le problème ils posent
des pièges de sa fabrication par exemple
mais ils comptent surtout sur un
champignon parasite un biopesticide
qu'une firme spécialisée est en train de
développer avec son aile alors c'est un
pauvre avec un champion super on est
ailleurs qu on va pulvériser soit au sol
soit dans les branches il ya deux trois
ou quatre jours après la banane et celui
qui vole ou là là on peut les tuer
facilement
bertrand gravel a accepté cette année de
collaborer avec biopterre il leur
fournit des arbres à planter et des
branches pour un programme de
reproduction in vitro un peu de son
verger devrait donc bientôt se retrouver
dans les parcelles d'essais du bas saint
laurent
si biopterre continue à la lignée qui
est qu'ils ont choisi ils vont produire
des choses exceptionnelles pouvoir
transformer puis ils vont pouvoir
s'organiser avec des producteurs pour
rechercher parce que on est encore alain
brion la danoise aurait alors est-ce que
le bas-saint-laurent deviendra un
paradis de la noisette
il est encore beaucoup trop tôt pour
l'affirmer moi c'est ce qui motive je
voudrais le le fait d' aïda zain dans un
produit comme ceux qui qui est un peu
précurseur pour la région on avancera ça
sera peut-être nos enfants qui en
profiteront
là